little name check for you earlier by uh
michael gove but clearly you're not
completely happy with the
government's policy on kovid 19 what
exactly are you asking for
well sophie businesses across the uk
report that they are frustrated and
angry
they feel like they can't see a clear
strategy to both
manage the pandemic and ensure that the
economy can keep
functioning and the fact is and this is
not discussed enough
every additional restriction that comes
in every
new local lockdown means less demand in
our businesses
more companies forced to shut their
doors and quite simply not enough
support for those who find themselves in
difficult
situations to then trade out thereafter
so it is a grave situation for business
to be in
it does require greater clarity and
greater action on the parts of
government
there's been talk uh about further
national restrictions a
are calling for a two to three week
circuit breaker uh we heard from jeremy
farah who thinks that it would be a good
idea as well member of sage
what would the impact be of more
national restrictions on businesses and
also on jobs
well the impact of either local or
national restrictions
can be severe you've got the firms who
lose all their demand but technically
can
remain open and you have those that are
closed by law
and the impacts there upon individuals
livelihoods upon entire communities
will be felt for a very long time to
come that's why when all of our chamber
leaders across the country
wrote to the prime minister today we
said it was really important to
set out the evidence clearly for all
steps being taken
make sure you're telling businesses
exactly what it is that they need to do
increase the amount of support that you
have on offer
over and above what the treasury has
already put on the table
and really really importantly set out
what an
exit strategy is going to be from these
lockdowns
you've got places like leicester that
have been under a form
of local restrictions since june of this
year
with no prospect of how they then get
out of them
so i have much sympathy with local
leaders around the country who are
saying
if we go into this how do we get back
out again because that's exactly how
many businesses feel too
yeah it does feel as if the restrictions
lasting rather longer than anyone would
have intended
at the beginning i know it's very
difficult but can you quantify in any
way the amount of jobs that are at risk
here
it is impossible to say you you could
you could certainly say that hundreds of
thousands of jobs
are at risk we hear from businesses all
the time who say to us
if i'm closed down again i will not
reopen with the consequences that that
has
for their employees because companies
aren't like
light switches you can't simply switch
them on and off repeatedly
and then go back to normal as if nothing
happened and i think that message needs
to get through more strongly to our
political leaders
both in westminster and in the devolved
administrations as well
simply switching things off for a couple
of weeks and then expecting businesses
to pick the pieces back
up dust themselves off and go back to
normal
isn't the real world and i think that
message needs to get across
when i talk to scientists about the
how you weigh up you know the economic
costs and the
uh the need to suppress the virus they
say that actually
these two things are not different
because if you act swiftly to suppress
the virus
then the economy will be helped
do you think that is right or do you
think that actually
the hard lockdown is clearly having an
economic
impact as well well i think all of us at
the moment are being presented with some
sort of false
choice between public health and the
economy when in fact the two go
so closely together if you don't have an
economy that can function
livelihoods for people etc the outcomes
in terms of lost
income in terms of community deprivation
mental and physical health
are extremely severe as well we should
be looking
at the moments to countries like germany
or new zealand or korea
who have managed to combine public
health measures with good support for
their economies
no secret there those countries have
good mass testing
and they have support for businesses
that rolls out throughout
the calendar year 2021 so businesses
have some certainty as to what's coming
ahead i don't want to make that false
choice i don't want this to be
scientists versus businesses in any way
it's got to be both together because we
need both an economy
and to suppress the virus at the same
time uh now i want to talk
to you about brexit i spoke to michael
gove
earlier on the show who said that he is
now less optimistic that a trade deal
will be struck by the end of the year
number of 10 have said that the talks
are efficiently
pointless if you like unless the eu
moves
their position and compromises more how
concerned are you that we're heading to
a no deal scenario at the end of the
year
well businesses are hugely concerned and
it is not the preferred outcome for the
vast majority
of companies around the country quite
frankly sophie what businesses feel they
are living in is a bit of pantomime
theater between the two sides right now
if as has been reported the two sides
have gotten closer on a number of issue
areas we want them to stop making
declarations to the press
get back into the room around the table
and secure an outcome
that's what's in the mutual interests of
both sides in this discussion
and and rather than convening press
conferences that's
really what we need to see